so with the news will Brad be facing a
PR nightmare today a source tells us pit
is consulting with a new york-based
strategy firm to help handle the crisis
if Brad Pitt was my client I tell him he
needs to talk to the media he needs to
tell his side but if you look closely it
seems Angelina came out ready for war
from the beginning accusations from
unknown sources claimed brad has anger
issues or had an affair we're told Brad
psy has said nothing negative about
Angelina with these allegations Brad
still horrible but there's gonna be a
wait and see women if they find out he
is involved in child abuse his
reputation will be splattered into movie
star bits other headlines include rumors
of marijuana brad has never tried to
hide his pot smoking pass I remember
being at a New Year's Eve party with you
many years ago it wasn't me you just all
might roll these perfect joint and now
you gave it up what did you yeah I'm a
nut you know I'm a dad now you wanted
you want to be alert back in two
thousand four Brad told us how hard it
was for him to just stop smoking
cigarettes I think I was homicidal for
about three or four days I was homicidal
and fortunately no one got hurt and I
made it through that but well now i'm
smoking again so sorry yeah i'll get off
again
you